hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast phage antibody selection with
Reichert spr systems
I am Brenda Kelly Kim lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes and sponsored by Reichert
technologies life sciences liker
technologies part of Ametek is a
preeminent player in the design
manufacture and sale and service of
optical refractometers that are integral
to the study measurable effect of
biological interactions for more
information please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem to the green Q&A button while we
left this is an educational webinar and
thus offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the C e button located in the
bottom left-hand corner of your webpage
to claim your credits I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Mark
Sullivan dr. Sullivan is a research
assistant professor Department of
Microbiology and immunology and director
biomolecular interaction laboratory at
the University of Rochester he received
his Bachelor of Science in chemistry
from Purdue University and his PhD in
biochemistry from the University of
wisconsin-madison
he was a postdoctoral fellow department
of microbiology and immunology
University of Rochester Rochester New
York
research in dr. Sullivan's laboratory is
focused on the manipulation of immuno
globulin molecules to develop novel
reagents for characterization of protein
expression and structure he and his
colleagues at record are using phage
antibody technology in several areas of
proteomics I will now turn it over to
dr. Sullivan for his presentation
good morning so this has been an
interesting start as you may know we're
at Chester just got hit with five inches
of snow this morning so welcome to
spring and then you know what I'd like
to do today is give it a brief outline
of what we'll be covering so I'll start
with some basics of SPR technology and
then move on did a little bit of
background and antibody generation and
modification using phage display that
I'll give some some objectives and the
rationale for using investigating the
record system for phage and done a
display and then show you some pulmonary
results we obtained in fractionating
phage on the DSR 7000 BC instrument the
main focus will be on binding and
recovery of the phage looking at the
effect of single-chain valency and the
display valency on binding profile as
well as actually getting some
separations between positive binders and
nine vectors so surface plasmon
resonance has been around for just about
the same amount of time as phase display
both were developed around 1990 it's a
label free technique for analyzing
biomolecular interactions in real time
it's an extremely precise mass sensor
and you can do quantitative binding
measurements with it it's a flow based
system and the key components are the
sensor chip where the ligand is
immobilized a micro fluidics system for
delivering the binding partner and
analyte and then finally an optical
sensor to measure the changes in the
residence angle that is translated into
a mass accumulation on the chip and SPR
really is the gold standard for
determining kinetics of protein protein
interactions and it's been used
extensively in the field of antibody
technology which is what I'll be
addressing today so just a couple
key parts of the instrumentation that I
want to go over so the sensor chip is a
small bold coated glass slide that's
been surface functionalized for
immobilization of ligands and there are
several options for doing that probably
most commonly used are being coupling
with EDC and HS you can also put using
that same coupling system you can put
streptavidin a new travitt and down for
binding by two lated ligands and finally
you could also use the files on the gold
surface and it's optionally can be
formed with a polymer matrix to give a
little bit of a balance between binding
sites and signal strength although all
the work I'll be describing today was
done with the planar chip without the
polymer on there so antibodies form the
largest class of new therapeutic agents
there's a large amount of activity in
the pharmaceutical biotech industry for
deriving new antibodies for a variety of
diseases and conditions so the very
first commercialized antibodies won't
mouse monoclonal antibodies that were
humanized since then and really consist
concurrent with the development of the
SPR technology they're really now a
variety of methods for generating human
antibodies that are much faster than
relying on hybridoma technology from
from mice so the two methods that are
most commonly used now so the newest one
really is the human antibodies derived
from high-throughput single D cell
cloning methods this is very powerful
and many of the new anti flu and anti
HIV antibodies have been developed using
this methodology however a major
limitation is that it's really limited
to agents that humans have already been
developed and you know community to and
then you that you can actually get
access to to their b-cells for them for
cloning there's a large number of
targets
that's not possible and so more recent
work has been devised as alternative to
generating antibodies and that's
basically the display technologies of
which there are several phase displays
the oldest was developed in late 80s
early 90s and it is probably the most
widely practice and the simplest of the
technologies to work with subsequently
there's been yeast display ribosome mrna
display as well as some cell based
methods but phage display is really the
workhorse of the display technologies
for generating new antibodies or other
proteins that are backed equivalently in
antibodies so this is just a graphic
that sort of distinguishes the multiple
display technologies the key concept for
all of these of course is that it links
the biochemical properties of these
displayed antibody to the genetic
material that encodes antibody and the
two travel together and the nutshell
that's what all the display technologies
do and I will only be talking about
phase display but these there's much
overlap in these technologies in terms
of how they work and the kind of results
the yield so the main advantages for
display technology in generating
antibodies of course is that it is
extraordinarily fast compared to the
traditional hybrid element technologies
in getting antibodies monocle binders
and approximately a week with phage
display and some of the other techniques
and that could frequently take months if
you rely on any mutations not only that
but we're not subject to limitations of
immunogenicity and so you can go after
antibodies to self proteins and this is
a very important advantage because much
of the pharmaceutical industry is
looking at antibodies that can mediate
activity of various receptors and ion
channels and humans and so that you
couldn't get this easily by
immunizations because of the conserved
nature of the targets we also this
technology
we'll also avoid problems with you know
dominance and you have many different
ways of presenting the target antigen to
the various display systems and so you
have a lot of control on that some other
benefit is that at the end of the cycle
when you actually have obtained binders
you can easily get proteins for analysis
of course it doesn't use animals which
is useful and you get of course the DNA
encoding the antibody which allows for
further manipulations control of antigen
presentation really is is a fairly key
advantage of display technologies and
that allows you to use some custom
conditions during enrichment so for
example to to directly select for higher
stability antibodies or control cross
reactivity of the selecting population
as possible so for the work that we've
been doing we're using a large what's
called the naive human feed antibody
library for most of these libraries that
are available the diversity ranges
somewhere for good libraries between 10
to the ninth and tenth eleventh clones
you can use the antibodies can be
expressed in phase display using either
FA B's or single-chain at these Oh the
work that I'll be talking about today
was is in a single chain at the format
many of these libraries have been built
using pooled cDNA from many donors to
try to give maximum sequence diversity
and the immunoglobulins and the binding
the prints of the the Selective pressure
that's that is applied in selecting and
enriching phage anybody libraries is
basically the shape complementarity
between the target antigen and the
antibodies that lets us select anybody's
to virtually any target whether it's
human human library human antibody
library on human targets is completely
viable and the generally the affinities
that you get from these libraries range
probably from 10 to
from ten to the ninth sighs naive
libraries I should mention that there
are other methods of generating sequence
diversity in libraries so this there's
several approaches to making synthetic
diversity on a single framework they
based large gets similar kinds of
results as the naive library is made
from cDNA however many applications for
therapeutics and diagnostics do require
a higher affinity antibody and
oftentimes in the sub nano molar range
and that's unlikely to be generated from
the kinds of libraries that most people
who might have access to so as I said
from a 10 to 90 size library of 10 to
100 nanomolar it's probably a upper
bound for high affinity unless one is
extraordinarily lucky of course so to
get our generate higher affinity what's
typically done is you take candidate
clones and they subject them to
secondary
diversification using either things like
error prone PCR or also you can don't
believe a nucleotide and do define
positions where there's extra diversity
created and then we select those second
populations secondary libraries under a
variety of methods to select for the
very higher high much higher affinity
antibodies probably the most common
method to do that uses biotin lated
targets and then using magnetic beads to
select who enriched for clones with
slower off rates and there's there's a
fair bit of procedural differences in
how one does this one of my favorites
actually required week-long incubations
and a beaker full of buffer to select
for slow off rates so just briefly and
and and so the library that I work with
relay this was generated as we use a
collection of light and heavy chain
family primers coupled with
J primers to PCR the light chains and
heavy chains from a pooled cDNA from
quite a few donors and rings in several
hundred dollars really and when you
generate those two fragments they can be
overlapped using standard slice overlap
PCR technology to assemble the single
chain in my case almost all a single
change I work with are in the light to
heavy orientation there are some when
the reverse orientation which actually
will become important later on and then
I use the vector that I built quite a
few years ago when I was in industry and
it uses employees using the flag tag as
an n-terminal epitope tag I'm the on the
end of the amino terminal end of the
single chain and we use this mainly for
detection but as you'll see that it has
some purification properties that are
also are attractive in any event all of
the single chains have an M terminal
flag on them and for those of you
perhaps not familiar with what the flag
is it's eight amino acid sequence for
which there are several very specific
antibodies available for binding to it
and then the vector that I'm using is
the NE it's called 83 six it uses an
Outland phosphatase promoter to derive
the single chain gene 3 fusion protein
while doing to get the phase display and
the point that I want to make about this
is that unlike a lot of other vectors
that have been developed for phase
display the reason we the fillet is
attractive for promoter is that keeps
the expression level rather low in the
cell when and then when you're producing
phage it's a very low level promoter and
standard lb medium and that encourages
true mono valent display or close as one
can usually get to it some of the other
vectors that are out there
use repressed lack promoters and in my
opinion those are much higher low basal
levels of expression so the odds of
getting multiple display on the
antibodies Rises significantly and so in
general my experience has been you want
to keep the expression level of the of
the single chain gene 3 fusion as low as
possible and so that's as the all of the
work they'll be talking about is using
this vector and so this side just
reiterates how things display actually
works to get binders at least in my view
it's actually just finding the right
puzzle piece that binds to antigen in a
complementary fashion so that you get a
decent binding interaction that can be
selected out by phage there was probably
some charge interactions buried into
this as well but by and large what
you're really doing is sifting a billion
billion piece puzzle for the four or
five or six pieces that surround the
surf that are complementary to the
surface of your target so sort of the
simple and easiest way to do phage
enrichments or bio painting this was
originally described by George Smith in
late 80s and it works well and we used
it all the time so you take a micro
titer well and coat passively coat
target antigen in the bottom of it and
this is a standard lysa methodology so
you coat the target you introduce your
phage library to it and let let what can
bind mind you then go through a series
of wash steps and then you loop what's
what's remains in these wells typically
with acid or base and then you get a
population that comes off comes off
these wells and then that is
reintroduced back into the coli and Yuri
infect with helper phage to get a new
secondary population or a second pool
that then repeat the process and after
two three or four rounds of this you
then derive binders they identified by
Cinco Lisa so and then so what drives
these enrichments of course is just the
difference in binding over background
and this is just a simple bar chart that
I had used for many years this was the
very first single chain I ever cloned
back in about 1991 when I was at Eastman
Kodak and it's an antibody against the
happen phenobarbital and it's just
illustrating that the difference in
binding between putting at this stage
antibody on its target being
phenobarbital conjugated to BSA
relative to other irrelevant targets
conjugated to BSA or just in the case of
this tackler race
directly bound to a plate you can see at
least three orders of magnitude increase
in in binding to target so that's that
thousandfold differential is what drives
the enrichment of lar very large
libraries in ten to ninth to ten to
tenth diversity down to a handful of
clones after two or three rounds of
enrichment so the phage display cycle
can be thought of in really two parts so
the first part that I just I just
Illustrated and this is illustrated
again a little bit different way but the
same concept is your libraries apply it
to your target be buying you wash you
loot and then those are really growth
and then you reapply that population you
know back around to the to the original
to another fresh round of the binding
and washing and Ellucian and that
usually happens
with most libraries probably 2 to 2 to 3
rounds sometimes 4 arms in my experience
it's often too round it's obvious that
it's working sometimes three rounds
almost never have I used more than three
rounds of enrichment for the library
that I have which is about 10 to the 9th
diversity but these things vary with
libraries I think in vectors and so your
results may differ nevertheless and this
takes at least the way I do it it takes
about 2 days of cycle to run the binding
and we and we grow the alluded page so
about 6 days and you can do three rounds
and then you're plating and then
amplifying the clones and testing of
confirming them by phage Eliza and then
often the initial clones you've got you
know they'll be moderate moderate
affinity and you may need additional
affinity enhancement and that would be
the secondary mutagenesis scheme which
basically is run conceptually very
similar to this except you're using the
methodologies for example with the
soluble antigen and by Attilio target to
to do to actually drive for higher
affinity and you'll notice that in this
slide the mutagenesis was successful
because mutagenesis is misspelled so we
know it worked um one of the other
things that one might be doing sort of
simultaneously in this cycle is taking
several candidate clones and testing
wanna test the affinity directly and
that requires protein expression and so
when we look at this entire process
we're where we could try to use an
instrument like the Reichert spr
instrument to try to accelerate and
improve this process there's really sort
of two areas that we can think about so
the first is in is in the is in the
actual selection process can we use the
microphone on the chip to possibly
enhance the speed
which this happens and so that's one and
then you can think also that it's
possible that we could actually analyze
individual clones in the fades level for
binding rather than at the protein level
now I don't really not going to really
cover this in too much detail but if we
actually think this actually could be
very powerful and if we can overcome a
few of the issues that I'll be
describing it in momentarily but beyond
just accelerating this this process one
possibility that comes to mind is to use
the controls on the flow system and the
buffers that we apply to try to improve
the effectiveness of the process so for
example we could start to control the
temperature time flow rate concentration
of elements to try to specifically
select for the kinds of antibodies we're
looking for and in which case that might
make the whole process much more
efficient now this is also a possible
way of accelerating this process if we
can eliminate some rounds of enrichment
you know potentially one can imagine
doing a single round if one can
eliminate background and only get a
highly enriched population of binders to
survive after one round of enrichment
that would cut down the time
considerably and then the other
possibility is to start to think about
how to increase the selectivity of the
antibodies simultaneously with the
selection so for example there are many
cases where there are several targets
that one is isolating the antibody to
may may be homologues and you don't want
to hit other versions of say a receptor
but you need some specificity for a
particular isoform of a receptor then
one way of doing
would be to do us a selectively
subtractive enrichment where you perhaps
in a multi-channel instrument you can
you can use some of the lanes to select
for binders to the ones you don't want
get rid of those subtract them from a
population that's then moved to a
channel with the actual target and that
way we can force the selection to be
isoforms specific and so that would be a
very powerful method potentially if for
those targets where there are other
isoforms present or the other
possibilities but the four channel
instrument is to run up to four of
instruments simultaneously and so that
would allow you to multiplex efforts
considerably so one of the advantages
that we saw in looking on the record
instrument for this is it's a relatively
open system and importantly the fluidics
are really quite simple and readily
accessible and so that means we can
literally tear this thing apart exchange
the tubing it's a very inexpensive
components the tubing is fairly cheap
the sensor slides are pretty cheap
there is no fluidics master control
board that you have to purchase that is
fairly pricey and then we can easily
collect the the outflow from the
instrument and reroute it so we can
unhook the the outflow and teens out
into a fraction collector really or in
our case we actually did it manually and
just simply collect in tubes
that can then be analysed offline so
that coupled with the flexibility to
employ different evolution buffers flow
rates and temperatures we think lends
some real attractiveness to the idea of
using this instrument to actually do the
phage enrichment and as I mentioned you
know the appeal of doing a subtractive
selection is rather strong also because
in my experience some of the exist
ways of doing this aren't really very
effective so the key questions we want
to address in this project we're really
quite basic but needed to be addressed
before one could even think about some
of these more exotic applications so the
first you know can antibody fades the
applied binder target and they can be
recovered in the outflow in the system
we didn't really have any any any
guarantees that this would actually work
and so we needed to demonstrate it so
another question was if you do this and
you do buying phage to in the channel do
they generate a significant SPR signal
that would be useful for monitoring not
just enrichment but also analyzing
individual binders when you get them
this also was rather unknown because if
you think about it in in the least in
phase display you've had a single
antibody molecule at least in mono
valent display attached to a multi mega
Dalton long filament and the interaction
between the single antibody and the
target antigen has to be strong enough
that the phage body itself gets gets
held up and binds so that you can
recover it and then in a flowing system
of the SPR channel it was not entirely
clear and least on first principles that
this would work well and then secondary
to that is how many fades can bind to an
immobilized target that was also a
concern because I don't really know how
to translate the amount of protein that
you might immobilize - how many phage
can bind there and so the reason that
number is rather important is because if
you're doing library either enrichment
or secondary libraries where you're
looking for affinity maturation even
though those libraries are probably
smaller than the initial libraries one
would use the amount of phase that
combined into the target is going to be
the upper bound of a useful library
enriched themselves
you can only bind a million pages that
you couldn't it doesn't make any sense
to make a library of more than a million
members to try to fish something out
because it's almost guaranteed to miss
what you're looking for so so that was
and a question we needed to address and
then subsidies how does the valency of
this plate single-chain affect the
binding profile because while we attempt
to make mono valent display antibody and
using these mono valent vectors they're
unlikely to be all mono valent there's
undoubtedly some level of by valency
present and if you have multiple
antibodies on a single face particle
those will come off the target much
differently because they're binding by
avidity effects then mono valent would
be and so that could complicate under at
least interpreting the data you're
seeing and then finally you know what we
really need to address this is how to do
this separation and we're basically
going to be running the equivalent of a
chromatography system and the important
the important parameters here are that
so normally when you bind and say an
antibody on to a chip under a target
antigen on a chip and switch it to the
dissociation phase you start
dissociating antibody almost immediately
except for very very high affinity ones
and so what does bind initially when you
switch over to the dissociation or or
washed up if you will things will start
peeling off instantly and we need to be
able to sort of run the system long
enough to get rid of the not either
things that don't mind because they're
non binders actual binders who don't
bind because they didn't bind in the
time period that you floated across the
target chip or those have to be sort of
reduce an amount before we can any loot
them what is bound and these are all
going to be variable because different
antibodies have different affinities and
so we needed to really sort out how this
worked before we could even think about
some of the more interesting
applications down the road so you might
wonder so how is spr been used
previously for binding Alice well the
answer is really not very much as I said
earlier a phase display and SPR
both developed in the early 90s that's
quite a while there had been a few
papers describing phase selection with
spr analysis but the early papers didn't
really give a whole lot of detail as to
how this was done and there's some more
recent papers that have been published
couple years ago there was a very
interesting paper published you looking
at peptide display that they at least
gave a pretty detailed analysis of what
kind of spr signal they were getting and
how many phase they were putting on and
the condition under which they did that
but the phage those are obligatory
multivalent display which I'll go into a
little bit in a few slides and so that
offers some challenges in interpreting
what's happening on the SPR chip because
of again because of avidity and
multi-site binding but nevertheless so
we were hopeful about that by if we can
control implement this control of the
phage enrichment using these instruments
fluidics on the record and if SP arsenal
offers improved discrimination of
affinity variance that would be a major
advance in the field so we set out to do
this by just taking sort of standard
preparations of fades which were
generated after infection when the
helper and in sort of the standard
small-scale approaches that people do
routinely and used it an antibody that I
previously selected to bind to BSA as a
very inexpensive and relatively won't
behave target that we could work with
and mobilize to good levels on the SPR
chip and we pretty much quickly
discovered that that using is just a
regular helper phage infected single
chain crop phage antibody prop games of
some rather challenging problems and
that's because the tighter of this is
quite high and the order of ten to the
twelfth per mil and transducing units
and the phase is flowing through this
even though the age that even though
it's all a BSA binder of course you have
a large amount of face particles that
have no single chain on it because of
the nature of the mono valent display
where that's the idea is that you want
to keep the display level on your page
populations down below 1% or so and
those 99% nevertheless still look like
you are cloned when you analyze them
recover them in e.coli you can't tell
the difference it's still a BSA single
chain sitting in the vector so what was
happening was these things sort of even
though 99% go through very quickly on
the and it's like the first flow through
fractions there's an awful lot of
tailing of the phage and so that could
have what was happening was it was
seeing the obscuring detecting the bound
ones that we eluded you know 15 or 20
minutes later so that was the non
displaying fade it was a real problem
with us and so we had to come up with a
workaround on that and they might also
add that at this point we also weren't
really seeing any SPR signals so that
was problematic as well so the solution
that we employed to do this was to
purify those fades that actually have
single chain honours on the surface and
the way we can do that is as I mentioned
earlier we have an intermodal Flag
sequence on the end of the single chain
and so we can take a population of phage
and first bind that finish part of the
height the high concentration States
population to anti-flag antibody and
that's the most immediate way to doing
this is simply coding as you know sort
of strip eight level strip with
anti-flag introducing the phage to it
let it bind and one appealing advantage
that we initially employed quite a bit
was that we could take those phage and
recover them without doing anything
harsh to the bound phage so rather than
using low pH or high pH to elute that
and run the risk that that could
conceivably damage the antibodies we
actually can use three X like peptide
and just incubate that to the washed
strips
and that pops most of the anti flat of a
single chain barring phage back off the
plate gets it a solution without any
damage at all and and so that's actually
what we tried to do and so we would then
we could put that phage preparation
which they shorthand call em to 3x and I
will put that into the into the system
and then and then monitor what comes
through and then what happens when you
allude it so just to diagram what this
experiment is doing is we're ejected
fairly small amounts mainly driven by a
time factor we're injecting a hundred
microliters of these fades preps we're
using a fairly slow on rate ten
microliters the minute and the reason
for that is you know we've looked at
some of the literature those people that
bother to tell us this and so the
consensus seems to be a very slow flow
rate for the binding phase of this is
useful and that sort of makes sense
because again you're having to capture a
multi mega Dalton phage antibody with
the interaction of a single a single
integer target antibody complex and so
we were concerned that this would shape
all Terron rates dramatically relative
to say an antibody or or even a by
fragment like an FA B or single chain
and so it seemed prudent to cut down the
flow rate lower than we might otherwise
do when analyzing same op and by regular
antibodies so we flowed that on and then
after it's it's gone we would switch the
floor a backed up to a more conventional
we typically use 50 microliters a minute
and run that for about 20 minutes to
wash off the phage that are going to be
you know the non binders or non binding
population although technically they saw
bind but the reality is many come
through initially and so we have to wash
that out before we try to elute with
acid and then we take these fracks
and we can transduce them back into
e-coli
so that measures how many phage
interaction as well as we can then you
know just confirm what has happened in
this experiment and what we observed is
you know if the phage inputs about 1
times 10 to the 8th we were getting in
the L youlet which is again an acid
treatment after about 20 minutes of
washing we've got two fractions for lu8
we are getting about 3 by 10 to 6 or 3
percent of the input so that's a little
lower than we've seen it coated well if
you did this exact same experiment in a
coated well we we'd probably get
somewhere between 10 and 30 percent
recovery my suspicion is that this is
mainly due to the difference between a
static Eliza well and then a flowing
system so you might imagine that some of
the phage
because also because of the size and
they're not sitting there for a couple
hours as would be typical in a in a
coated well experiment that we just
haven't given them enough time to bind
in so you end up with a lower amount of
phage that actually stick to them to the
surface so that's sort of the downside
is we have to balance giving it plenty
of time to bind but on the other hand
even bound fate should start bleeding
off just by the normal off rates and you
know especially in a flowing system like
this so the amount of phage you can
actually recover upon dilution there's
going to be you know have to sort of be
fine-tuned to take into account those
two parameters so here's the profile the
difference profile between channels and
as you probably can see right away you
know this is the honoree and the on
phase and we aren't seeing really any
signal at all in the SPR and but
nevertheless we can pop these things off
with the acid treatment here and when we
entered this we actually did did get
this and I'll show you some more day in
a second
we after we do this we run an anti BSA
in about
just to verify that the surface is still
functional nd this is a fairly sis is I
think at 26 microgram per mil antibody
and so you get a very nice robust signal
here coming off the antibody so that's
at least telling us that the surface was
fine
so despite what doesn't look like a very
impressive SPR signal we nevertheless
did get signal in the eluded phage and
so we we were at least encouraged by
this now as I said in our original
experiments where we had the mono valent
display which you know is diagrammed
here so what happens is you've got at
least in our hands with the helper and
vector combination I'm using we think
that this maximum display is about 1% of
the phage particles are displaying
single-chain and and so 99% don't so we
you know this is what we were using to
eliminate the 99% so that we hopefully
not have to have to worry about those
contaminating the outflow but there's
also a possibility of doing multi build
display and the way we can do that is to
use what's called hyper phage which is a
special helper that's deleted for gene 3
and we use that to infect the cells that
contain the vector with the BSA antibody
on it all of the phase that are produced
come out multivalent and in general it's
believed about 3 to 5 copies of the
single single chain or g3 protein are on
the end of these phage particles so the
one downside to doing it this way is
that in with my vector since the
expression level is so low in general
the yield of phage is not great coming
off I'm afraid so it's considerably
lower than then you would see what they
standard helper but nevertheless it's
plenty high to do these experiments we
usually get 10 to the 11th per mil with
the hyper phage and these are multi
bailer
so we wanted to use a multivalent plate
to answer this question it can we get a
better signal and B how many phage bind
to the to the surface and the channel
where their multivalent and presumably
have a much higher rate of success of
binding and staying on the chip even
when you switch to the wash and in fact
we think that's exactly what we've seen
so now we take a preparation in this
case is about 2 by 10 to the 11th fades
per ml we apply them to the inject amend
and as you can see we get a steady rise
in spr signal during the on rate phase
we switch to the to the wash phase and
you'll note that not a whole lot changes
it's pretty flat and I think this is
expected because as I mentioned this is
multivalent so there's the fade you
likely bound by multiple multiple
binding interactions and that won't come
off easily and so this is entirely
consistent with that so we do this
experiment and after 25 minutes we by
monitoring the titer we're actually
getting down pretty low in the
background and so then we loop with acid
and we found that we could be 10 we
cover about eight times ten to the
seventh page or a 25 what 25 fold higher
than when we try to mono valent approach
so the good news was a we there is a
signal that fades bind we just have to
figure out how to get it with a smaller
number of phage in the mono valent
display but secondarily there's plenty
of capacity to bind and so now at least
we can we can appreciate that much
larger type libraries could be applied
to this to a channel like this I should
mention that in this case we put down
about fifteen hundred micro I use a BSA
on the surface so it is a fairly sizable
amount of material that was bound and so
but nevertheless we were gratified to
see that we were getting a fair number
of fades back and certainly much larger
than we saw with the mono valent so so
now that we were convinced that the key
parts of this idea were at least viable
meaning that we could put phage on there
and and you know the capacity is there
so we wanted to be able to ask really
the basic question before anything else
can be can be pursued is do we can we
can we separate the binders and non
binders so we used a rather artificial
system but the thing is that to simplify
the expense and time involved in
analyzing what happens in these
enrichments I came up with a trick that
I could use to make it much simpler and
that is I had a a different non binding
clone that it turned out was in the
opposite orientation with respect to the
heavy and light domains of a single
chain that I had used for some other
experiments and so the BSA binder is
represented on the top and that's my
standard orientation light chain link or
heavy chain and when you colony PCR
transductive using primers that flank
the single chain actually the the front
primer flanks it up in the leader
sequence but the downstream primer that
I used actually Prime's in the three
prime end of the heavy chain domain the
VH so it's a vhj primer so so that PCR
product would be about eight hundred
bases if you do the the opposite
orientation then that primer is landing
only about four hundred bases away from
the the upstream primer and so the PCR
product you get using the same primers
there's only four on your basis now the
advantage this has is that we could we
could do simple colony PCR without doing
any binding analysis to figure out which
close
it's represented in a particular colony
by just running the PCR products on the
sizing gel and it's 800 it's the BSA
clone buts 400 it's the non-binding
clone so that's the experiment we set up
and so run very similar to the one I
just showed previously so we inject a
mixture of phage it's about a one-to-one
mixture of the pepped it was an anti
peptide antibody that's the reverse
orientation and the peptide isn't isn't
the BSA of course and then in the and
then BS a clone was mixed with it and so
that was set we tired this it was m to
the M to 3x peptide purified we set the
input to about 50/50 did the same kind
of experiment we inject for a minute for
10 minutes at 10 microliters a minute
switch the wash speed up back up to 50
collected fractions and then did a
solution at the end of the wash phase
which was at the end it was about 20
minutes so then we get colonies from
each fraction so that gives us the titer
of the fraction so we can calculate how
many fader in each fraction and then we
subjected some sum of each fraction to
colony PCR to measure the percent the
composition of the fraction in terms of
percent between the the negative peptide
binder and then the positive BSA binder
so this is what sample of those results
look like it's not I didn't have
everything I want gel so there's a
little couple panels missing here but
nevertheless what you're seeing is that
you can easily distinguish between the
BSA clone which runs here and then the
peptide one which runs at this size and
and so it's very easy to see that that
we have a mixture and then you go
through the wash phases that mixture
stays still get both things out there
I'm not showing on this particular gel
wash for which I had previously done
which again it was a lower level and
it's starting to drop and there's you're
picking up more of the well you're still
picking up the
cup-tied one but then when you switch to
the l youlet in this fraction and in
this fraction you see almost entirely
well in this in these two examples you
see entirely to be assayed lighter
coming off in the acid and then the
other gels that I didn't include this we
actually picked up a single clone the
being of the peptide binder and the
eluent
but in any event and and for those of
you who are actually paying it careful
attention to this slide you'll notice I
actually have one clone here that gave
both signals and presumably that was a
double colony that I picked
inadvertently and so both both have both
plasmids and in the PCR reaction in any
event though it's a very clean
experiment and very easy to see that we
were getting selectively the BSA binder
and the acid Ellucian of this after the
washes so I summarize how this
experiment worked this is a plot of the
among number of the amount of phage and
each fraction the the width of these the
columns here is proportional to the to
the volume of the fraction that
collected so the flow-through is the
smallest and then the wash and the value
it's were roughly 250 micro liter
fractions and down down here is I've
tallied the BSA binder versus the
non-binding peptide antibody in each
fraction that we found and as I said you
know in these two fractions and the
aleutian fractions there was only a
single clone out of the 28 that I
analyzed by PCR and and so what's like
this the basic system is it's functional
in that we can get binders and we can
flush the non binders out and still
still recover a sizable number of the
the binders in the outflow and so I
think that
our basic idea that we can use the SPR
system to do enrichments binding
enrichments in in the SPR instrument and
so that that left us with some good
feelings about this
so the key results though to summarize
this is that it's easy to apply to phage
we can fraction eight them and and and
they're easy to recover from the outflow
it's you know I did it manually but you
could easily imagine putting the outflow
tube on a
Gilson fraction clock there the
old-style Wilson fraction collectors are
just collecting collecting fractions
when we're putting on ten to the eighth
mama bailiff agent we can get one to
five percent off that yield is probably
dependent on both how much target is
immobilized in the channel but also on
the affinity of the antibody that's
binding to it I could imagine that with
different affinities you'd get a
somewhat different result on this but we
have have yet to show this the maximum
binding is significantly higher as and
then you validated that with a
multivalent binder so I don't think that
we're going to be limited to doing you
know in terms of the amount of phage
that can combine to the to a channel
obviously this is probably also a
function of the amount of mobilize
target we haven't done a lot of
experiments unchecking that how that
affects the binding but that of course
would be a reasonable thing to do
clearly this would probably be much
simpler if we could increase the number
of displaying phage in the output
without going increasing the valency so
one possibility comes to mind is not
using a static microtiter coded ante
flag set up to do this but perhaps an
actual small column of my m2 agarose ad
flag on arrows might might work a little
better and finally of course increasing
the input phage might also be used for
although
it's unclear to me how many phage
binding a coated well so that's the same
problem we had with with the the SBR
channels we don't really know that so
that's that's an area that needs to be
worked on a bit just to see what that
the best way to do this might be we can
clearly separate binders from non
binders and that was that was what we
were hoping to achieve the parameters
such as flow rate dilution buffer
composition will likely require again
some more customization how that plays
into the affinities of various
antibodies is unclear you know we
couldn't we didn't look at using some
people like to use base to do the
Aleutians my experience and the pH to
glycine has always worked better in
terms of getting number of fades back
off of a target but you know other
people may have other reasons for using
base I think there's a lot of other
possibilities for composition of the
Aleutians of the aleutian or
regeneration buffer if you will that
might be worthwhile there's a paper that
was published not that long ago that
developed a cocktail approach to
optimizing regeneration conditions on
SPR in a way that that maximizes
retention of structure of the target
those buffers might be worth looking at
in terms of doing the phage because
fades basically the phage dilution is
the same as you know conceptually and
it's the same process that used to do a
standard regeneration to do kinetic
analysis by SPR so except that in the
SPR you want to retain the structure of
your target or as in a phase system we
can dispense with that if you don't want
to reuse the Chuck so in any event is
probably some room there for
optimization as well
now the SPR signal in the monomial in
case it doesn't really come into play if
you're actually doing an enrichment for
a little bun that's binders you're not
using the SPR signal but that having
said that I think it could be very
useful if we can characterize the
individual claw
with varying affinities by that but it
will be essential to do mono valent
phage and so the challenge will be you
know how easy and convenient is it to
make a large amount of mono valent phage
for for a panel of candidates that you
can then use and test to see how they
look and by spr signal that will require
a little bit of work but in fact I'm
thinking that that actually could be
could be really valuable in terms of
accelerating the process of obtaining
clones via phage display using the Riker
SPR for the actually enrichment
mechanism so the reason for that of
course is that we'd be able to you know
we can skip the protein expression part
of candidates if we could do that and
and just do phage analysis and you know
people try to do that while by
competition Eliza I guess would probably
be the main route that most people would
attempt to to sift through their their
candidates to decide who's got maybe the
highest affinity before moving that that
candidate on to a to an affinity
enhancement program how well that works
is you know I guess that depends I mean
the times I've tried it I haven't been
altogether impressed with the
discrimination in affinities and so I
think having having a better system that
you could do by using the SPR would be
wonderful but it's going to take some
some some additional work to show that
that's true and mainly in terms of
getting a signal on a mono valent that's
really the critical issue there as we
mentioned earlier you know I think this
has the potential for eliminating rounds
of enrichment especially if one does the
pre enrichment first with a ap flag and
you're putting just binders on I think
that couple with some some stringent
wash conditions might be able to cut
down the number of cycles you need for
one to one or two
that would be a nice savings and also we
might be able to use the Aleutian
conditions to actually select for higher
Effendi miners right off the bat that
would also be a useful trick to have and
finally getting specificity to homologs
or you know or closely related proteins
to your target would be really nice and
if we could actually run these
enrichments directly on the the chip
that would also be really nice and I
think that's entirely feasible we
haven't been in a position to try this
yet but in fact I think that's something
that could be very powerful and would
like to see that that experiment done it
and finally if you're just doing
different targets you could put four
targets on a four-channel instrument
that also is a nice time-saving as well
so again just to summarize you know
we're I think you know the basics the
basics look favorable but we do there's
still a lot of work to be done to really
to really implement this and a system
that you can rely on and so we know for
example one possible technique that we
should probably test is soluble target
Ellucian so you just you know you but
let's say for example we've bound to BSA
then we just flow on BSA and me in the
wash buffer and that should help pick
off as the antibody is released from the
surface they can be bound up by the size
of our target so if you have a running
an affinity enrichment we could probably
just you know look for things that
survive introduction of various levels
of the target in solution in the flow
and then wash buffer also manipulating
flow rate and temperature what could do
the trick to in particular getting a
nice little temperature bump as the wash
buffer goes through might be useful in
getting getting a higher higher affinity
clones to retained in the system and
again as I mentioned characterizing into
individual phage binding to rank order
affinities would be a huge huge benefit
if we can get the prep on the phage down
to a two at least
a manageable amount of work and again
subtraction schemes I think will be will
be highly desirable so I just wanted to
end with this promo for the pigs meeting
where a Reichert will be I have a booth
and be happy to field any questions of
England has any thank you thank you dr.
Sullivan for bringing that important
information to us before we get to the
questions which we already have a few
coming in I just want to remind our
audience to submit your questions
through the Q&A box which can be found
by clicking on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window I will try to get to as many of
the questions as we can today we do have
our first question in the Q&A box why
doesn't the sage binding and the
multivalent binding reach a steady state
well my my sense of this is probably
that we you know didn't sit we may not
have saturated binding in the first
place
at least I mean if you talk about the
multivalent one it actually you know we
switched over to the you know after we
gave it an arbitrary amount of finish
going in
it was stayed on and I think in that
case it's quick well clear me that the
multi valency was preventing anything
from coming off that that that channel
so that that'd be my best best
explanation for that it's just it's just
too much multivalent and I should
mention that there was a there is a
paper in the literature from the early
90s that was looking at a peptide by s
page by SPR and they had a they actually
published the profile and that thing is
was virtually not coming off as well and
unfortunately they concluded that they
had a loan animal or binder but I
suspect that this was a you know began
obligatory multivalent I think that's
actually what they were seeing was not
high-affinity per se but just a
multivalent effect okay
moving right on to our next question is
the purity of sage preparation a key
factor
well I guess I'd have to qualify this
answer by saying it's not you know what
do you mean by purificatory I think I
think it's helpful to do the the
anti-flag purification because that
definitely gets rid of virtually any any
impurities that you might have but I
have put more more crude samples on here
and that I guess the main problem of
course is you don't want to clog the the
tubing so but but I've put centrifuge
preparations and I think you could also
filter phage and retain the Fate the
phage go through a like a point form
Lantern filter so you can do that so I
don't think that that level of purity is
a problem I mean obviously you don't
want to be have a lot of bacteria or
anything in this and you go through and
and and certainly I you have to be
really cautious about we suspending your
phage from if you're doing a peg
precipitation which most do because
there's a lot of junk that doesn't
Reda's all've when you do that but you
know I I don't think it's necessarily a
problem and certainly you can run a
point four five microns purification if
one is concerned about it
great our next question why did you
choose to use the planar sensor chip as
opposed to the polymeric coating
that's an excellent question we did this
this is primarily just Mike and my worry
so so here's the thing so spr has been
around for as long as phase display has
so that's you know since 1990 so you
know that's that's a lot of time and
very few papers actually talked about
putting phage on these chips I asked
myself why might that be and okay so one
possibility was it doesn't work okay
well I was hoping it wasn't that but my
suspicion was that the instruments that
were basically available it from many
places are rather expensive instruments
and have rather sophisticated and
expensive to repair fluidics and I'm
thinking that people are concerned about
putting on you know really those kind of
preparations that someone else is going
to be coming in with proteins that are
you know a little more sensitive and and
concerned about it so in thinking about
this as well is that the other
possibility is that those are generally
have the dextran surface on there and as
I said you know if you think about
trying to drag along several million
dollar page in an antibody on the end of
it I was concerned about the kinetics of
how that would happen and if I add to
those concerns the additional issue
about penetrating the dextran layer it
seemed to me that that was possibly not
going to work just on the basis of
what's actually having to happen when it
binds to a dexter and layer where the
targets could be buried down a little
further
so my inclination was to use the planer
to simplify this and not have to deal
with the possible effects of the dextran
but I'll admit that I haven't done a lot
of a lot of work with the Dexter and
chips it could either fine I just
haven't tested it yet
okay questions are keep rolling in our
next question did you think about
injecting a secondary antibody once the
phage binds to increase the magnitude of
the signal in fact in fact they did not
think about doing that that's probably a
pretty good experiment although it's
hard to imagine that we'll decorate it
enough to see a significant difference
in mass the other thing that one has to
keep in mind is these phases are bound
to the target by their by one end and so
most of the filament presumably is
dangling up in the liquid phase quite a
bit further from the surface so it's
sort of unclear to me you know how much
how much bang for the buck you're going
to get if if in fact since the SPR
signal should be dropping off rather
dramatically as it gets further away
from the chip one of the papers that I
talked about well actually I didn't talk
about it but I mentioned it that was
published using a fiber optic SPR signal
actually has a diagram in there paper
contrasting the two modes of binding by
the gene 3 protein at one end of the
phage versus gene 8 along the length of
it and how they were concerned about
getting a differential signal based on
how they bind so it's possible it is
possible that you might increase it and
we should probably try this but it's
also possible that because of the end on
binding it we wouldn't really see a
whole lot of benefit to doing that but
I'll admit it's good experiment
great thank you we have time for just
one last question before we wrap up an
attendee asks do you think it's also
working with peptides phage display well
in principle yes in practice
doubtful and the reason I say that is
because from as I understand this and
I've talked to one of the leading
experts and kept I display about this is
that generally speaking even from
multivalent libraries like the new they
have at libraries for example that you
can get from New England Biolabs you
generally speaking the affinity of those
peptides as going to be rather modest
and in that case it's going to be hard
to accumulate enough on the chip to spot
that now they are multivalent so you do
pick up the avidity effect so it's
possible but so it might work for the in
for like an enrichment type experiment
but but the paper I was just mentioning
about the fiber optic system they
actually did everybody a favor they
actually calculate they compared the SPR
signal in their system which admittedly
I think is a custom system that isn't
commercially available so it's hard to
interpret that but they compared the
Eliza signal to the to the SPR signal
they see and also quantitated how many
fades they were putting in and I can
tell you that most of their phage clones
that Rin will affect all the phage
clones that they reported that were in a
in the 3 to 5 male at gene 3 system you
had to put in at least 2 by 10 the 11th
to get any signal whatsoever off of it
and and and they only got fairly modest
signals when they went all the way up to
10 to the 12th phage and that's actually
kind of tedious to get on those stages
that's a lot of phage to put in so and
by the way if anyone wants to
yes I can I can I can provide that link
to that paper it's pretty interesting
paper but anyway my suspicion is it
wouldn't work all that well for cup-tied
pages and I actually I saw one of the
other questions there that I want to add
I'm gonna go ahead and address this
anyway because they probably should have
spent some time on it somebody asked a
question about contamination in the
system and this in fact is a concern you
can use the you know the sort of ultra
clean protocols that are online that you
can use where you you ask that News base
you can use urea you can use SDS that
helps swapping out the tubing is also
helpful but yes in principle if you've
put a lot of a phage on and you want to
do it again later on for the same target
that can be problematic I do have a
workaround on that for affinity
maturation but from basic libraries if
you have if you're going to repeat an
enrichment from a life from a library
like naive library or you know a general
library you do have to be worried about
it and and in fact that could be a
little bit tricky to get it completely
cleaned up sterilized but but but you
can you can run these cleanup protocols
and they work pretty well so it might be
manageable
Thank You dr. Sullivan that is all the
time we have for questions today I just
like to ask dr. Sullivan if he has any
final comments for our audience
well you've been a great audience now
seriously though yeah it's uh I think I
enjoy having to give to be able to sort
of look outside the box and have a tried
to do some some non-conventional work on
the Rikard SPR and one thing I can tell
you is that and the record system to me
was much more flexible than maybe going
to some of the other instruments and and
so I think there's a lot there's some
potential there if we can just do a
little bit more development work on it
but in any event I appreciate the
comment the questions at the end there's
a very some very good questions
great I'd like to thank dr. Mark
Sullivan again for bringing this
information to us and of course thank
our sponsor Riker technologies life
sciences for making this educational
webinar possible attendees will be
receiving an email from lab roots to
alert them when this broadcast will be
available for replay that replay will be
available through October of 2016 and we
would invite you to tell your colleagues
who may have missed today's event about
that replay that's all we have for today
thank you very much we hope we see you
next time